Okay, well, so I've shown you that historically people think badly.
Well, why do they think badly is our next question...
...and I have some renditions here.
This is an example of what's known by psychologists as groupthink.
Groupthink means when you're part of a group that wears uniforms,...
...or has a secret password or what psychologists call an in-group,...
...it's really hard literally to step out of line...
...with the decisions of that group.
A member of the national security council of the United States government...
...blamed groupthink for the unanimous decision to go to war against Iraq.
The Asch Experiment.
The Asch experiment basically was again was...
The Asch experiment was put together by a psychologist...
...of that name.
And he discovered that if you have people look at the line...
...on the left and then ask them, "Which of these three lines, A, B or C,...
...is the line on the left most like?"
If nine people say A, the tenth person, not knowing the other nine people...
...are collaborating in advance with the experimenter,...
...that tenth person will almost invariably fall in line and say A as well,...
...showing the power of social uniformity.